the estranged husband of a missing
Connecticut mother of five is now a
suspect in a case that's made national
headlines
police arrested foetus Doulos and his
girlfriend Michelle Trac ona's Saturday
they make their first court appearance
today mola legi is at the courthouse in
Norwalk Connecticut molla what are the
charges
well good morning Anthony this
investigation is being treated as a
homicide the couple that you mentioned
is now facing charges that include
tampering with and/or fabricating
physical evidence as well as hindering
prosecution in the first degree now
Jennifer Doulos has been missing since
May 24th so we're going on about ten
days now meanwhile her young children
are said to be safe in the care of
Jennifer's mother as this case unfolds
on Sunday Connecticut police descended
on a home owned by 51 year-old Fotis
doulos for more than a week
they've been combing through woods
looking in dumpsters and deploying dogs
in the search for his estranged wife
Jennifer the 50 year old was last seen
leaving her children's school her car
was found by a park shortly after she
was reported missing by friends she's a
lovely person Kerry loved has known
Jennifer for nearly 30 years she's
incredibly devoted to her five children
they are her world in June 2017 Fotis
called 911 time his wife filed for
divorce and left their family home
mergency worried about my wife and kids
because they they left to go to work and
I haven't ever since photius and
Jennifer had been involved in a vicious
divorce and custody battle according to
the Stanford Advocate newspaper in court
documents dating back to 2017 Jennifer
said she was afraid of Fotis and he had
shown irrational unsafe bullying
threatening and controlling behavior she
also allegedly claimed Fotis had
threatened to kidnap their children and
take them to his native Greece Vitesse
denied all of those claims
hundreds of people gathered Sunday night
at two separate vigils to pray for
Jennifer and her children we are bound
by our common humanity by our hope for
Jennifer court documents reveal that
foetus may have had financial problems
Jennifer's mother claims that he owed
two and a half million dollars in
outstanding loans we did reach out to
Fotis his attorney but have yet to hear
back Tony
mola thank you very much